Marvel's Avengers is a third-person
action-adventure game featuring an
all-new original story where you play as
your favorite Avengers
the story starts on a day at the opening
celebration of the Avengers West Coast
headquarters in the reveal of the team's
new Terrigen crystal reactor
but after being blamed for a disastrous
explosion that leaves San Francisco and
ruins the Avengers are forced to disband
due to public backlash and government
pressure in their absence a new
organization Rises vowing to protect the
world advanced idea mechanics otherwise
known as aim five years later the world
is a very different place in their
pursuit of a safer future through
science aim has replaced superhumans
with their advanced synthoid AI but
under the surface the signs of a
conspiracy against heroes begins to
unfold with all superheroes outlawed an
Avengers fan girl from New Jersey named
Kamala Khan embarks on a quest to prove
her hero's innocence and become who she
was destined to be Kamala plays in a
central role as the catalyst to
reassemble the team with her unique
perspective and incredible powers only
together can the Avengers overcome the
dangers in this new world you'll start
by establishing a base of operations in
a decommissioned Helicarrier which gets
upgraded throughout the story you can
customize your harrell's to play solo or
assemble online with your friends
defending Earth from ever escalating
threats each of the heroes has tons of
outfits inspired by over 80 years of
Marvel history as well as original new
ones as you play you'll earn an unlock
tier equip different gear pieces to
customize your play style and become
even more powerful powerup gear by
unlocking perks which will change the
way you play the game
unlock skills and abilities as you earn
experience and build your heroes to fit
your play style
using the war table you can launch into
two different types of missions para
missions are the single-player campaign
experiences showcasing specific heroes
and warzone missions which are played
solo or online with up to a total of
four players all missions drive the
narrative forward and all of your hero's
progress is shared across the entire
game
reassemble the Avengers and rebuild the
team to be Earth's Mightiest Heroes once
again